[Music]
when you called last time you've been
using a long time right yeah i had been
smoking weed every day for about eight
years at that point tell me about your
adventure you've been on so i have been
sober completely sober for 62 days today
i'm so excited i'm so proud of you
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
dolone show greatest mental health
podcast ever
said by nobody
except for us
and by us
there's like a bunch of people back
there maybe like two
and both of them are on the payroll so
it's just a thing they do because
they're loyal
so glad that you're with us if you want
to be on the show give me a call
1-844-693-3291 it's 1-844-693-329-1
a couple weeks ago i asked folks man
reach out if
you've got something good that happened
some good news some things are going on
and i always am asking people to follow
up with me
in this first call i'm super jazz man
elizabeth
from roanoke she was uh smoking weed for
ever and ever and ever i'm in and
um she is calling with a pretty
incredible update elizabeth you there
yeah i'm here how are we doing
you know i'm great
boring and sober now right
boring and sober but but really really
good so i wanted to give you a call back
and tell you how it's going i okay i i'm
number one i always ask people calling
me back nobody ever does so you get the
gold star on your forehead today which
is incredible i don't know if that's
where you want to put a gold star that'd
be not a great place to put one um okay
so hey thanks for calling b tell me
about your adventure you've been on
so i have been sober completely sober
for 62 days today
and i've noticed some really incredible
changes in a lot of ways that i never
even expected let's stop right there and
what like everybody wherever you are
listening to this
and
there's
lots of you
everybody start cheering clap and start
cheering wherever you happen to be
grocery market mowing your yard and your
like dad's shoes your nike monarchs and
your tall black socks just start
clapping wherever you happen to be um in
your squad car whatever it is super
excited for you congratulations
elizabeth uh okay
walk us back give us a 30 second rewind
when you called last time you've been
using a long time right
yeah i had been smoking weed every day
for about eight years at that point and
i was on the fence about quitting for
about like three months by the time we
talked going back and forth back and
forth
and my biggest fear to stop was that i
wouldn't be able to tolerate my feelings
and i wouldn't know what to do with my
time
and
that really stopped me for for months
quitting
and i'll be honest after we talked i
didn't quit i it still took me a few
days
how soon after we got off the phone did
you light up
like i don't know if it was immediate
but my feeling was immediate it was just
like i gotta get high it was me yeah i
wanted to get high after talking to you
actually i'm just kidding um
so
that's a very common thing i'm glad you
mentioned that often people will have
this big moment they'll have this hard
conversation
and then they'll go use again and then
they think well now it's all over and uh
and actually no like you okay you're
there and now let's take the make the
next right step right and refresh my
memory refresh all of us listening
was there a couple of things you were
running from what was the weed helping
with
well the weed i was really using to
self-medicate for depression it seemed
like my emotions i i couldn't handle
them before and i would use weed to
escape
and when you said you couldn't handle
them what did that what does that mean
like be
be specific for it because there's gonna
be somebody listening out there being
like i can handle them i just don't get
out of bed for two days and i eat a
whole bottle of ice cream and whatever
right so
what does that mean i couldn't handle
them
so i think the two biggest things that
were so uncomfortable for me were severe
depression so the depression that gave
me hopelessness feeling kind of what's
the point why are we doing anything kind
of this total empty depression
and agitation
so if i'm feeling angsty or edgy or just
uncomfortable those are the two main
reasons i would i would turn to weed to
escape that
and so you what was the day you said i'm
done
a few days after that i just was
wheezing again because that was one of
the big factors is that my lungs were
not healthy and i just decided i'm i'm
going to try and i actually did start
the book you recommended um dopamine
nation so i was listening to that on
audiobook and i was already kind of
compelled within the first few pages
it's fascinating isn't it pretty good
it's amazing yeah it's amazing dr lemke
uh we'll link to the show notes many
other people already yeah i i'll link to
the show notes it's it's just one of
those books that comes along once every
10 years and it's just
so good man so good okay so you listen
to that book you got convicted and you
said enough's enough what did you do
next like did you throw everything away
did you have a bonfire what'd you do
well you know actually at the time my
husband wasn't ready to quit so
everything was still out okay i just
made up my mind and
that was it i made up my mind so i
didn't really mind that he was still
using or that it was around it wasn't
for me wow kind of put it out of my head
like that okay and you can usually white
knuckle that for
a couple of days couple of weeks
what was after that
well that was what you know and i
remember like when i re-listened to my
episode that i was on which you said i
guess really stuck with me that i didn't
connect until i re-listened which was
this too shall pass and that's something
my therapist had said too and i think
that's been the most powerful tool for
me getting through anything is that the
emotion will pass and so if something
was uncomfortable i just remember it's
temporary this will pass i'm
uncomfortable but it's not forever
and
with this eye on the prize of i really
wanted emotional balance i really really
desperately wanted emotional balance so
i was willing to do this experiment for
that outcome ah so good okay so in the
past and you've been sober 60 days
62 the last 60 days in the country
there's been wild political upheaval
there's been economic people are
screaming and yelling and jumping out of
building like it's just mess
um it's a billion degrees all across the
country like
you picked a really dumb time to get
sober quite honestly and and if you were
like trying to get off cocaine this
would be a great time right but to get
off weed
this is a tough time how have you
managed this for 62 days
it is really crazy out there
but i would say just keeping my eye on
that prize like i wanted emotional
balance more than anything i i
i became sick and tired of being sick
and tired yeah that was that was my last
depressive episode
and i just didn't want it anymore so
despite everything else that that was
kind of the pinnacle like the the bright
light through it all was just i i need
to see if this is going to be curing my
depression
and
um and i will admit the first two weeks
were hell like you said i think after
the first two days i had
excruciating headaches for about 14 days
like these really intense tension
headaches of taking advil which i don't
ever take right and i took it every day
for two weeks i mean it was that bad um
and then day 14 boom it was it's like
somebody peels off a cataract huh like
you start to see things clearly yeah
it's wild okay so
often i see folks give up a thing right
and they've been an addict for a while
and again we're talking about levels
here getting off heroin is different
than getting off alcohol is different
than stopping smoking weed which is
different than stopping pornography and
cheating on your way whatever but when
people give up things
and say i'm making a long-term behavior
change i'm playing a long game on this
one and you really tattoo this too shall
pass on your soul right
often they don't refill that gap with
other healthy behaviors and it ends up
that vacuum pulls them back have you
added have you started doing things like
exercise or yoga or drawing have you
have you backfilled your life with other
things are you still hanging in there
yeah
no i have and i knew that that was part
of it going in so i knew that it was
going to be part of the plan that even
if i didn't feel like it i had to do
something with my time and shockingly i
haven't had any spare time i've easily
filled it
i have my first garden my first
vegetable garden which i've been looking
forward to for years so that takes up a
whole lot of time
i did start exercising
i've i'm exploring the windhoff method
and cold exposure don't drive while you
do that by the way
you know i remember you saying that you
might wrap your little
prius around a
cinderblock highway divider just hashtag
just saying
um that's fantastic man yeah that that
is actually the the wim hof breathing i
think is a powerful this too shall pass
because you begin to take ownership of
you go further upstream than this
two-shot pass and you begin to take
ownership of
the feeling before it even heads down
the road it's pretty remarkable once if
you go down that rabbit hole for a while
that's awesome
yeah all right yes i've had no shortage
of things to do that's for sure that's
so great you're you're incredible
you're like seriously like i'm smiling
and i haven't had a great day and i'm
smiling because
it's just amazing
here's the hard question so if i if i
describe it this way for some reason it
makes not for some reason it's pretty
obvious but it makes things less
difficult so also i can just do the
dishes i can just do the chores and i
don't have this extra
gripe and frustration and oh i have to
do that again so when i remove that kind
of groan over everything in my life i
actually can do a lot more which also
then fills your time so it's kind of
been two-fold in that way who are you i
don't
who are you that's incredible okay so
i mean you'll you'll get this down the
road right now you're in 62 when this
becomes 90 and becomes 120 like the
this will you'll start you'll you won't
count minutes as much as you'll count
days as much as you'll count weeks as
much as you'll count months and this
will become a part of your life
and you'll look back and you've done
some pretty extraordinary things because
you're moving your body and you're
changing your thoughts
and you are
getting a new connection to yourself i
mean you're making all these shifts
here's the big one are you ready
has your
um significant other stopped using
you know what he has what he's now 20
days sober dude peer pressure
yeah i know middle school style
okay so no i mean
no guy makes their own decision i'm just
kidding he may have good for him but
there's a zero percent chance that's
true
and
if you all both need to tell yourself
that that's fantastic so
he watched you
just come out of a cocoon and he said i
want to be beautiful like that too
that's fantastic has he is he through
hell yet is he on the other side of it
he is yeah and it was about two weeks
also that's pretty miserable so he's
about a week in where he can see and
acknowledge color again
yeah
and both of us we had some a little bit
some bad news some difficult news
yesterday and we got through it it's
it's amazing it's it's really given us
this both of us this tolerance for
difficult things
like i said before with the depression
it's like if i was always like if
there's a baseline of depression i was
always kind of skirting and jumping
right on that line but now i'm not even
close to that line like i'm nowhere near
feeling hopeless i i i can't even tap
into hopelessness right now and that
used to be kind of just like under the
surface all the time so i feel really
liberated from that that's so incredible
do you have a game plan for when that
when when that siren calls do you have a
game plan
yes i'm gonna remember that it will pass
and it will pass and that will be okay
because i think it's when you are in a
depression you feel like that's your
whole world that's the whole world
becomes even heavier that's right but
it's not it will pass and it always does
pass yeah the the lie of depression is
it's always been like this it always
will be and it was your fault right and
one or two of those things may be true
but in totality they end up dragging
underwater here's what i'd recommend
kind of like we have a fire plan
right like in my house i have a gas line
that goes to an open flame and i've got
two kids 12 and under like there's a
there's a really good chance something
catches on fire in my home right
um
we have a plan
just for in case
and so i would think and this would be a
fun exercise for you and your counselor
to just say let's write it down maybe
it's on one piece of paper and we store
it somewhere where we know where it is
and this is elizabeth this list
elizabeth's depression plan
if and when my baseline goes low or my
blood sugar falls off and i begin to
feel like the old days or fill in the
blank right mom gets sick whatever the
thing is
i've got that map to get out of the
house when it's on fire already i know
where it is
and that way i'm not going to listen to
my body signals in those moments because
i know they don't tell me the truth i've
already got a plan from when i was well
and i'm going to follow that plan even
though i feel like x and y i'm going to
follow that plan i'm going to stay above
that baseline you see what i'm saying
yeah that's yeah you're incredible can i
ask you one more this is a personal
question and i can edit it out if you
don't want to answer it
um
two
recovering addicts
staring at it at each
other what's intimacy been like
you know you can leave this in the show
it's actually been much better okay i
think i mentioned to you before this all
was triggered because we wanted to start
to try to have children
and
that's been a huge change for us it's
like our sex drive has improved our
intimacy has improved we actually want a
baby even more because at least for
myself i'll speak for myself i feel more
capable i feel like i actually could
handle having a kid wow so it's been
really great there's something about sex
driving increases and that's a common
thing people stop smoking weed all the
time
there's something else about
looking across a room at somebody
unclothed and saying do you see me and
i'm allow you to see me right you know
what i'm saying and so for you to say no
no that's that's improved that's that's
such an incredible moment for you and
your
ex
i'm just i'm like i'm so i'll smile all
day that's not all day
i'm really proud of them too so i think
that's sexy you know like i really i
admire what he's doing and he's like
doing a thing he's the same
yeah gosh and you're gonna catch him
lifting weights one day and then geez
louise man stay away from the elf house
i'm so excited i'm so excited i'm so
proud of you um
like for real i'm so proud of you one
last thing will you keep this in your
back pocket
yes
i don't i think i'm breaking some sort
of rule or something by doing what i'm
about to do and forgive me if i am okay
is that cool
if one of you slips one of you
uses one day
i want you to be about your new identity
not about this magic number okay
okay i've had i've had people who are
recovering from addiction in my life who
i love that their life revolves around
this magic number
and less about the person who they're
becoming and there's days that
um especially in the old days when i was
an idiot
i knew a couple of guys were gonna ask
me hey what'd you do for your wife this
week
and i would do it the night before i
hung out with those dudes so i'd have
something to tell them
and so there was something about
practicing like i'm doing things even
when i don't think about it when i don't
feel like doing it um there's moments
when that's good and so there's gonna be
moments when like i'm at day two twenty
two i'm not i'm having a bad day i'm not
gonna do this so i can get to day 223
there's there's there's something there
but that number will never be your
identity
okay
you're bigger than that yeah and you're
that
new sexy guy you found he's bigger than
that
and now y'all are on this new trajectory
in this new path and as two people who
are going to honor and steward their
themselves and their mirror dude i'm
just like i'll smile all day because of
this i'll smell all day i'm so happy
well congratulations
thank you and is it all right if i like
share one last thing if someone's on the
fence you could share anything share all
of it yeah you've i mean you've told us
about your sex life for god's sake what
else you want to talk about
i'm married
so i really would encourage someone to
just try
and it's really intimidating but if
they're dealing with mood problems like
depression that this is just a gift you
can give yourself to just try it and the
worst case is you get 30 days clean and
then you can go back but i cannot i
cannot believe how much it's impacted my
mood and i've struggled with depression
for
decades and so if i had known or
believed that stopping weed would change
and like liberate me from depression as
it has i would have done it decades
sooner so yeah if anyone's listening
just give it a try just try it out the
worst that can happen is you go back
after 30 days the best is that you're
free from depression and let's let's
extrapolate that out that's more than
just weed
that's
um
your pornography addiction that's
working 80 hours a week that's people
who cannot put their phones down that's
people who are struggling with the sort
of eating
do something for 30 days just do
something for 30 days right and did you
find that number to be pretty magic
that's the number that's just constant
in the ethos stop doing something for 30
days and then reevaluate right
it was magic yeah i would say after 14
that was a real turning point and then
after 30 was even more so okay yeah the
the two weeks of hell is pretty routine
and then the two weeks of who what who
am i what is happening
and then that back two weeks is often
when people just don't think about it
they unconsciously grab a twinkie just
because it's it's it's behavioral you
know you go to do the dishes and you
just go look for the bong and all of a
sudden you're like oh no no right so
staying conscious in those two weeks as
you're beginning to see color again
i i'm just so proud of you and thank you
for your encouragement thank you for
calling us back we call me back at day
90 and day 120.
oh sure and what if you ever have a new
day one will you call me that day too
sure i will i'm so proud of you and i
want you to send us pictures of that new
little
knucklehead of baby that comes along and
just hashtag just saying john is an
excellent excellent name hey thank you
so much elizabeth we're so proud of you
and thank you for like giving us a light
to walk towards all of us me included
we'll be right back
hey what's up delona here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way burnout is when
your body has enough and it says i'm out
i'm done it's that deep feeling of
exhaustion after a long period of being
overworked and overstressed and just
fried and most of us associate burnout
with work but burnout can happen at any
area of our lives and it can cause a
lack of motivation irritability fatigue
or randomly crying at some random song
on the radio or when somebody looks at
you the wrong way and that's why i love
my friends at better help betterhelp
online therapy exists to give you the
chance to invest in your healing
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with you and your
therapist you never have to even see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy plus you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours and today
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
betterhelphelp.com
all right we are back okay last night my
wife and i went to see frank turner
who's one of my favorites of my
favorites of all the favorites and he's
like an acoustic punk guy from london
and just love him
and man sharing mosh pitting time
at a full punk show with my wife so
great that's cool thing number one
cool thing number two is we're starting
a new show segment that i'm making up
right now it's called i was wrong i was
wrong
i'm very happy about this kelly loves
this segment and so i think it's always
fair
um when i when i'm wrong on something so
a few weeks ago months ago by the time
this thing comes out um a woman called
and i believe she's from virginia
um and she was
trying to work through a divorce
and maybe north carolina something like
that it was something over that way
in the east ish anyway i kept saying
leave like go get the divorce and she's
like well i think i gotta wait a year or
something
and i was like that's insane
like you don't have to live apart for a
year just go file for your divorce i
think it's 30 days or something turns
out i was wrong i had people write in
and say in their particular state
particularly on in the eastern united
states
that in some cases for a no-fault
divorce
when a couple says hey we no longer want
to be married for various reasons
um they have to live in separate homes
and be separated for one calendar year
before the divorce goes through
that sounds clinically insane to me the
amount of economic damage you could do
to each other the amount of personal
damage you could do to each other the
amount of isolation alone like the whole
thing
um i'm sure somebody will tell me like
here's the reason why and maybe it was a
legislature that was trying to
discourage divorce so much um
usually when you try to do that the
person who suffers is a victim of some
sort of
abuse or something right it's rarely two
people that just shake hands and say you
know what we should just go our separate
ways and we'll be adults for a calendar
year
i don't know many married couples who
are adults that long without doing
something
anyway i was wrong i was just like dude
what are you doing and turns out i
didn't know my my
marriage law so there you go and then a
third thing here's the third thing
um somebody wrote in
and there was a call a few a few weeks
ago where
there was a mother who called and her
she had adopted um a child
and the more they learned about the
child the more they learned they had not
received the full story of this child's
history and
she had some rage and her some anger her
and her husband had some anger about the
way the grandparents had
um
taking care of these little kids before
they ultimately adopted them out
and
as she described the grandparents she
used words like
lazy and unengaged and
here's how they would parent and so i
said
i used the word abuse
and man i stirred up a hornet's nest
that's not abuse
abuse is when you're hitting somebody or
screaming cuss words in their face
so i looked this up
here's just like a run-of-the-mill
non-scientific run-of-the-mill
definition of abuse is to treat a person
or an animal with cruelty or violence
especially regularly or repeatedly
so
you can disagree with me
but i cannot sit here and look at the
data of what
disengaged
children
what their brains look like what their
psychosocial development looks like what
their relationship abilities look like i
can't look at the aces score for these
kids and by the way remember trauma is
something that can you can do to
somebody
or
not do things that i should have done
for a kid that i didn't do like i don't
have to hit a kid i cannot feed a kid
that's abuse that's something i didn't
do i don't have to
assault a child
i can walk past and ignore that kid and
there's scholarship there's tons of of
research that suggests if you don't hold
children if you don't acknowledge
children they die
okay
and so i'm can't sit here anymore
and
not anymore i never really have if you
repeatedly
stick a child in front of a screen
for six seven eight four
hours a day
and you deprive them of relationship and
you deprive them of their most important
needs as a young child besides food and
water and sleep which is a relationship
with a present adult
and we continue to outsource our
parenting responsibilities or our
grandparent responsibilities to these
digital babysitters
and then i look at
the emotional and physical and
psychological and relational
dysregulation going on in the minds and
bodies of these kids i don't have
another word other than to say that's
abuse
and if you're listening to this and
you're like oh crap i hand my 12 year
old an ipad and they're on it when they
wake up and they're on it all day
especially in the summer and then they
get home and i just
grab a drink and i throw my feet up
because wind down wednesdays and then i
watch my shows
and
yes i'm talking to you
and this is not gonna win me anymore
instagram followers and i don't care
it's time to reconnect with children
and to start looking at these
deprivation actions these withholding of
relationship from these kids
as abuse call it what it is
call it what it is
treating a person or animal with cruelty
that's what that is
and so yes i probably do use the word
abuse or trauma too much to try to
expand their definitions in this case
i'm holding to it i think i was right
all right that's it that's the three
things let's go to lauren and angola
what's up lauren how we doing
pretty good thanks for taking my phone
call of course you got it thanks for
calling what's up
uh so i guess uh overview of like me i
am a pregnant mom with three children
four and under and they
just i stopped there
wow
when are you uh what do you do
i'm due the end of september
so you'll have four under five
five and under
yep
wow
i love it though they're no i'm i i i am
i'm in awe of you i'm not even i'm not
making jokes i'm not making fun of i am
just absolutely in awe of you
congratulations fantastic thank you so
much wildness very cool okay so
four under five
four under five have health issues and
my children have some health issues and
stuff too and my husband
works all the time okay and he's almost
never home and so
i guess one of my questions is like
how do i navigate knowing like what
what is actual needs and what is okay to
say my needs are to my husband
when i know he worked so hard for us but
at the same time i feel like there's got
to be a balance of rest and quality time
mixed in there and like i understand
like we have a farm and he works
construction and some other things
but like i understand that farm life can
be challenging and stuff and i we knew
what we were getting into when we did
this but at the same time i feel like i
get the leftovers of him
um
man there's a lot of places to start
here what
why do you think
who told you
that your needs
have to be filtered through
all these different filters that you put
on them
i think a big part of it is i've always
been the
sick kid that always caused money to
cost money and took up way much more
time and everyone always had to work
harder for me
so it's a lot of like trying to be as
less of a burden as i am
so if nobody's ever told you this before
and i'm the first person to tell you
this i'm sorry
hopefully other people have told you
this
but you're not a burden and respectfully
i'm going to ask you to never say those
words out loud again because they're not
true
yeah it's
it's like a constant struggle in my life
yeah what what happened
my husband
he said what what health issues
i
mean they don't have a label on it
because it's really confusing but it's
kind of similar to like celiacs and
crohn's
but it's just
just chronic ideas
and headaches okay and um and like crazy
severe allergies that are like step down
from anaphylactic okay
so hey i got a great idea you should
move to a farm
oh it's it's honestly a huge help
because is it really because of all my
food allergies like we raise grass-fed
beef organic fed chicken non-gmo pork
and it's like helps because we don't
have to buy any of our meat okay all
right
um my husband's just not great at
balancing life and family and work
yes
so
you and i could go down a rabbit hole
together that i think would be a
distraction from the casual listener
so i will say this this way and i feel
pretty strongly about it
number one
a mother surrounded a mother who's
become a human jungle gym which is what
you are right
can be dreadfully and sometimes
frighteningly alone
lonely okay definitely that's number one
loneliness
a woman who
loves her husband your husband's a good
guy right
oh yeah he's awesome pretty amazing okay
and he's working his butt off he's not
hiding or running he's not like sitting
next to him he's working his butt off
okay
um and he's probably trying to give you
the life that you all talked about
having together right and you're trying
to give him the life that you all talked
about having together
yup yeah and now we're in a dance right
um
you love somebody who's just at the edge
of your fingertips
that you see just in time for him to
fade into a mist of sleep and right when
you open your eyes he's getting up to
walk out the door and get back at it
yep
loneliness is such a bio dysregulator
and it disrupts every part of your
physical body
and so what i want to challenge you with
is if you are paying as close attention
to your diet as you do
and you are trying to create a less
inflammatory state
inside of you
yep
the first place i would start
is with other people
not the dream
and i know that's hard to say out loud
so can you explain what you mean by that
yes
you are cashing in
relationally
you've moved out to a farm
you are missing
your other half literally
for this dream and what i want to show
you is this dream is costing you in your
health
in your
psychology in your emotional regulation
and it is causing your body to
eat itself from the inside out
okay
and what's keeping this thing going is
your dream and my guess is i can sit
down with your husband who's in year one
or year two or year three of working
20-hour days trying to keep this dream
going
pretty much since he was probably 16.
okay and working like this i have hung
out and loved and gone to church with
and been friends with
farmers who were very very old
and they left it all on the field
literally
right
and so the question i want y'all to ask
is
is your dream worth your health
is your dream worth your family
is is this life you're building
worth where you're headed
and so to answer your original question
is
your needs are always valid
and your needs are going to get in the
way if you will and i hate to use that
language but they're going to be
different than this cool picture that
you all have together
like me and my wife
i'm making this up but if we have some
beautiful dream house that we want to
build in the mountains
and then i break my leg
and my leg has to uh be amputated and i
don't have wheelchair access
then the dream is gonna have to be
different
see what i'm saying yeah and it's not
because i'm a burden it's because life
happened it just is and now we do
something different right
and so
your needs count always
i would say in fact i'm working on a new
book right now
and the the working chapter so usually
what happens is i write like a nerd and
then i let people read it and they're
like we don't know what you're talking
about so the working title of this
chapter is the biology of secrets
ultimately if you've got needs that
you're not communicating you're keeping
secrets and ultimately secrets from the
person you love ends up being a really
fancy way of saying you're being
dishonest
fair yeah
yeah okay
so i think it's really really important
that you sit down and say here's what i
need i need you
and i would rather have you than this
thing that we're trying to do
that's it's i don't know that's like
kind of my fear i hate being the reason
to mess things up
you know like i love i love our dreams
and i i feel like okay can i be can i be
super mean can i be super mean and not
mean whatever you want being direct
you can mess up your health
you can mess up your interpersonal
relationship with your children you can
mess up your marriage and keep his farm
or
you can choose to be whole
you can reimagine what your marriage is
going to look like
you can
be a
solid piece for
four under five
and then y'all can figure out what's
after that you see what i'm saying like
you're you're putting the wrong you're
putting the u-haul before the truck
yeah
and you're trying to push it on the road
it's like hard for me to think about
changing it because it's my whole
husband's life
and
yeah i i i reject that
you are your husband's life
yeah and those kids are your husband's
life
he's doing this stuff in service of
y'all
yeah
so here's something that happened in my
life
um
you've probably i don't know if you read
the book my book or you've listened to
the show at all um you've probably heard
of
when i needed to i i was working at
university it's time for me to go like i
was an anxious mess i spun out
um we ultimately took a 70 000 household
income pay cut to leave that city and to
go somewhere else we didn't make that
much money it was devastating
financially for us okay
um it's not like we're making 300 grand
and we like we had to suffer through
making 230 like we it was tough
and
the part of that story i don't tell
is that in that gap when we were leaving
there was a very real opportunity to
become a vice president
and i was all in
and my wife sat me down for one of the
first times in our marriage and this was
the beginning of us learning to
re-communicate to communicate anyway
and she said please don't
i need you
and it was enough that she felt like if
i go go do this new job
it might be it
and so it was that moment and i'm gonna
be honest with you i was pretty upset i
was mad it's all i ever wanted was to be
a vice president at in this job at this
particular place but that's all i wanted
to work for that for a long time and i
got pissed off and i kind of like him
through a hissy fit because i was acting
like a child like an immature brat
and now that i look back i cannot tell
you how grateful i am that she spoke her
needs out loud
i feel like that's kind of like what
happened to us just last week
oh
i'm not good at speaking my needs and my
husband is not used to me speaking my
needs or just assumed i did and i
finally said
i couldn't do something that he really
wanted to do
and kind of shocked him
because he wanted to go on this big trip
over the weekend and i'm like okay like
i trust you as my husband but if we go
on this trip
you realize like i have to do all these
things and i'm probably going to be
emotional wreck afterwards because i'm
going to be worn out
which lowers my immune system and the
kids i'm gonna have to watch them the
entire time because it's not a space
atmosphere
and but he
he wanted to do that but then i got sick
so
and that was probably
i'm speaking out of turn here because
i'm not a medical doctor but that was
probably your body saying
if you're not going to stop this madness
i will
yeah i feel like it was
god trying to give them
a hint
it might have been but it could have
just been your body being exhausted and
worn out yup
um here's a cool thing
and i say cool because it's going to
involve tears and it's going to involve
frustration and it's going to involve
practicing and trying new things that
y'all never done before
you are going to have to create space
for your husband to
think for a season that you have not
been telling him the truth
and it hurts
even though you haven't been telling him
how you actually feel or what you're
experiencing to the fullest extent
because you're trying to protect him
he has been working to the fullest
extent to try to honor you
and there's gonna come a collision there
okay expect it it's gonna happen okay
yeah
what needs to happen is
he still has i've worked really really
really really really hard and now we
have a four-day weekend or a three-day
weekend let's drive eight hours for
seven hours of fun and drive eight hours
back
this is super common when people have
young kids
one person generally is like well these
kids have to eat
and i'm the chief
fuel source for two of them and one of
them just rocket diarrhea's everywhere
like you know i mean like somebody
thinks through it and the other one's
just has like let's go to the lake dude
and
so here's what we have to do we have to
completely reimagine life
the life y'all had before does not exist
anymore it's over
yep the crazy farm life where he'd come
work and he'd come home smelling a
little bit but it's kind of hot and kind
of sexy and you're like oh there's my
farmer that world is over
right now
it's we got three kids another one on
the way
i'm i i still think he's sexy but you
should probably shower because i need
you to help put the kids to bed right it
just looks different now
and we have to reimagine what this looks
like
we have to build a new world because if
you keep trying to drag the past with
you into the present it causes
resentment and then people start doing
stupid stuff when they resent each other
yeah
and you're going to resent him
continuing to ask and he doesn't really
know the full extent because you're not
telling him the truth
and he's going to resent you because he
thinks you're just like you become a
burden and you're not a burden but
that's the way you're acting and that's
the way it projects out into the world i
think that's the main reason why i i
i know i'm bad about like thinking
things aren't necessarily needs because
i'm always trying to not be a problem
and so i think like i don't know he just
actually introduced me to your show just
like two weeks ago
well here we are
the
the most problematic thing you can do is
not tell the truth
yeah
it's not been intentional i know i
realize i know that i'm not and i'm
saying it mean and direct like that on
purpose okay i know you haven't been
lying to him um but you haven't been
telling him the full extent
and by hedging like i don't want him to
fully understand how tough things are or
i can't do it like i used to or i don't
want to do it like i used to want to do
it or we talked
for 10 years about our farm what it was
going to look like and we were going to
have all this healthy foods and we've
watched all the youtube clips and all
and now i kind of just want to move into
a five-bedroom house in a suburb and
have neighbors and people i can go get
eggs and sugar from without having to go
to the chicken coop with two kids
strapped to my back like
life changes
the only thing you're doing right now is
he feels that gap
of
of you're not being transparent with him
you're not speaking your needs he feels
that gap and he thinks that gap is his
fault
and so he's going to do the only thing
he knows how to do which is work harder
and longer
yeah
am i right
yeah i mean i feel like i don't know
maybe it's just a guy thing but if he
can't fix my
problem then it's just
it frustrates him and he works harder
that's right and your what ultimately
will happen is
he will
recognize in short order
he's better at the farming stuff than he
is at the husbanding stuff
he's better at the farming stuff than he
is at the kids stuff and he'll spend
even more time there because that's
where he feels
efficacious that's where he feels like
he knows what he's doing
and that happens with attorneys it
happens with people who run fast food
restaurants i'm just better at work it
happens here
i'm not very good at this show but you
should see me try to husband i'm not
good at that either and so there's some
days i'm better at just reading articles
and thinking of ways to talk about
anxiety than i am
sitting at a kitchen table listening to
my daughter tell me about dragon turtles
that you know that eat
i don't know i don't i still don't know
what we're talking about
i don't know how to do that and so it's
just like i'm gonna go get my
computer out and read another article
because i know how to do that and i've
got to learn to lean into the discomfort
and i can only do that when i'm tethered
into my wife and we are connected
connected
so it's time for a truth-telling time
and the way i would pitch this um you're
new to the show
you and your husband need to get
somebody to watch those kids all 17 of
them and you all need to have a half day
retreat or a full day retreat and walk
away and make three columns
what we dreamed about
here let's be honest about what we
wanted we wanted a big huge farm with a
big huge farmhouse and we wanted kids
running around everywhere we wanted
these things
and then the middle column is here's
reality my body's falling apart
we wanted seven kids i'm pregnant with
number four and i'm starting to get sick
a lot
and i'm having to feed two of these kids
and the third one is still like here's
where life is and that third column is
going to be
we got to reimagine what was and we've
got to have a new vision moving forward
it might be that you stay at the farm
but you have to hire some help
and it might be that you stay at the
farm but he commits to coming home at
five o'clock every day and not going
back out to run hay in the dark
it might be fill in the blank any number
of those things that you need help four
days a week with bedtime
it with bath time with breakfast time
with those things you need those first
and then we're gonna backfill work on
the back end or you're gonna have to
hire a housekeeper whatever it looks
like here's what this looks like moving
forward for us
and my promise to you is he's going to
exhale too
just like i did
your needs always count his due to and
the magic of being married is y'all
figure out how can i do whatever it
takes to meet your needs
while you're doing everything you can do
to meet my needs
and that often means doing different
things and either one of us would have
cooked up and that my friend is the
beauty of it all we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's take unimas
let's go to jen
back out in roanoke what's up jen
hi how are you i'm partying how about
you
not so much partying i'm not either i
just lied to you i'm not partying i'm
like sitting at work
like the furthest thing from partying
like i got water in my cup for okay so
what what's up
um i have a 21 year old daughter who has
recently attempted suicide twice
she is actually in north carolina right
now working at a summer camp because she
didn't want to be home while summer okay
um she's all grown up you know she
doesn't she doesn't need her mom how old
is she
21. okay
is there any history of this at all
um she had a history of cutting when she
was younger and we did counseling and
medication and things like that and
watched her very carefully and thought
that it was under control
apparently when she went away to school
she was about a six hour drive away from
us at college
and apparently she started cutting again
when she got there and we didn't know
okay
she was very good at hiding what she was
going through apparently okay
um what was the did you ever get a
diagnostic underneath the cutting
because cutting's a relatively benign
behavior unless it's attached to
i get like when somebody says hey my
kid's cutting my heart rate doesn't get
up um i usually want to know more but
this sounds like it was a enough of a
disruption
that
you all sought professional help
was she ever diagnosed with anything
not not that i was told from the
counselor or anything like that it was
just a depressive
anxiety disorder
well that's that's a
she's got a depression
yeah that's it yeah she's got an anxiety
disorder or a like major depressive
disorder that's that's a big deal
um
so what what is what has led to
like what would she say if she was to
articulate it to you or when you've
talked to her what would she say um
led to her attempting to die by suicide
twice
uh the first time
uh she did not get into the law school
she wanted to get into okay
and she was having a struggle with her
roommates one of them had been her best
friend
and she got a boyfriend and didn't have
time for my daughter anymore and that
whole story okay and she just was
feeling very lonely and isolated and
and of course when i talk to her oh yeah
everything's great everything's great
but it wasn't
and
so that time she cut herself
right down the forearm with a razor
blade
yeah um i didn't know it was a suicide
attempt at the time i was told that she
felt like she wanted to hurt herself
and went to the hospital
so i didn't know until she came home
that she had even done that who
classified that as a suicide attempt
um
the counselor that saw her after the
second one
okay
i never had any contact with the doctors
or counselors from the first one okay i
didn't know anything where she's 21 with
hipaa it's hard to get any information
would she not yeah you can't get any
unless she signs it was she she wouldn't
sign over
no
that's tough
yeah that's tough
tough stuff
um
so
ask ask me your direct question
i don't want to start answering
questions that you're not asking
um
i'd like to know what we can do as a
family around her to
prevent this from happening again
um i honestly don't think
no put us afraid i mean she's taking you
out of her life
um
you can
can i ask you a really hard hard
question
yeah
when you look back she's 21 and you look
back in the rearview mirror this is a
really hard question i got two kids okay
so understand my heart
behind while i'm asking this question
yeah um has there been environments in
the home that have contributed to her
feeling
untethered uh her father and i divorced
when she was eight okay
because of his alcoholism okay
and he wasn't very connected to the kids
okay
and she told me she did open up one day
a little bit
and said that she and her brother felt
like they were alone during that time
yep
um and i tried to
explain to her you know that we were all
going through that and i really was
trying the best that i could yeah
but um
most of the time
when was that did she talk to you about
that
uh just a few weeks ago before she left
to go to north carolina okay um
is it i'm gonna tell you something crazy
that's actually a beautiful moment that
you have okay so i'm gonna walk back
what i just said a minute ago about
nothing
okay
okay here's what she desperately needs
to hear and i'm not saying this is cured
like this is curative this isn't
preventative let's take those things off
the table the ramifications here are so
big
that it can be paralyzing
yeah
and the guilt that you feel that you
should fill in the blank is overwhelming
right
oh yeah okay
so you have to what do you do for a
living
i'm a psych nurse no you're not
i am
and i volunteer as an emt
um
so you know what
you know like before you called me
um
okay so but i was hoping that you had
some new insights i do i do i do i do i
do my promise to you as i do
your guilt is gonna be
x-fold
the normal person on the street
yeah because you not only think i should
have done some things differently but
you think i should have been the one to
stop this
i should have known that's right i
should have seen it
so here's what you got to do you got to
own that you have to acknowledge it and
you got to set that crap down sister
because that's going to prevent you from
reconnecting moving forward
and the path forward is reconnection
okay
so the only thing i'm going to get on to
you about and i'm going to do it like
you and i are sitting on the same side
of the booth eating nachos okay so it's
not me getting onto you like you dummy
it's not like that
i know it's me you gave me a a picture
that i want to push on okay
okay when your daughter comes to you
in a relatively fragile state
and says
we grew up in a wild house
yeah and
growing up in the home of an alcoholic
i mean you know that you know the data
on that it's madness right the the way
that ping pong's through a child's body
and then you add the divorce on top of
that and then you add that existential
question
what is so bad about me that dad chose
that over the bottle over me
yeah
that he chose those other women over me
is this gonna happen to me
like it happened to mom and then let's
be honest there were seasons when you
were just trying to survive and in a
nine-year-old or a fourteen-year-old
they wanna know where's mom
yeah or why is mom's door shut again why
is she crying oh crap it must be me we
must have been too loud i must have not
got the right grade right that's not a
fault thing that's the way kids are
wired
okay yeah so when your 21 year old
daughter comes to you and is vulnerable
for the first time
say the words i'm sorry not no i was
there too
okay okay here's what we're going for
connection not being right
the facts do not matter
she is trying with all she has to plug
into something that will hold because
nothing in her life has ever held
okay
so here if i'm you i'm this is not um
i'm not giving you some kind of deep
medical advice you know that more than i
do you're a psych nurse for crying out
loud you know way more about that than
me
i'm gonna tell you talking to you just
parent to parent okay and working with
countless college students in this exact
situation
if i'm you
i would drive down to north carolina
i would make a trip
and i would say hey
can i have an hour for coffee
and
i would start that conversation with
i was wrong the other day when you
called
and i'm sorry
i want nothing more in my life
than to meet and know and love my
daughter
and i spent a lot of years trying to
survive and now i'm going to spend the
rest of my life reconnecting with the
most important
two people on the planet to me
yeah and let's start there
okay and what we're doing is we're not
looking for
clinical things and you should be
feeling this we're looking for hi how
are you today
i miss you
i've been driving her crazy with text
messages i know you have i bought i know
you have yeah i know you have
here's what i don't like about her
trajectory is um
cutting's not a big deal until it is
right right
and there is um
dr joyner's got some exquisite work on
cutting
dying by suicide is such a
violation of your of a body of a
person's body
that yeah there has to be some sort of
ramp up to it
and so
um
cutting it in for a lack of better terms
can be practicing i'm practicing hurting
and i'm going to push that line i'm
going to push that line i'm going to
push that line and either my dad who is
a swat hostage negotiator so when
someone's going to take their life they
called my dad in
he would often say someone would climb
up on a ledge of a hotel and be about to
jump and he said i knew within a minute
they didn't want to jump i was worried
they were going to fall off
and that's what we're worried about here
i don't think your daughter wants to die
god i have not
nothing you've told me suggest that
i think she wants to feel something that
is real
and
yeah
she told me um when she talked to her
dad before she went to north carolina
that he hugged her and that it was the
first time in her life she felt like he
meant it
and that new
set of emotions is unmooring
like it's overwhelming for a body and i
just need to i just need that to stop
for a minute
i can't control that that's new feelings
for me and cutting re-establishes
control
yeah
and cutting didn't realize she'd been
doing it until she had the second
attempt she overdosed and when i went to
the hospital
i found places on her legs where she'd
been doing it again and again and again
yeah
so your daughter is not a problem to fix
at this point
right she has somebody to be with
and as a psych nurse you're gonna have
to turn that down a little bit
and she doesn't need another nurse she
needs her mom
yeah
and that's gonna be used doing things
probably different than you've ever done
no defense
no
coming out swinging by the way you've
been married to an alcoholic
yeah who left your family like you've
been through trauma too
oh yeah but yeah we there's there's a
huge of a hole for me we could go down
that's right but listen
very very common my guess is if your
boss calls out a performance issue you
are nuclear
and if your neighbors
call out to something like your lawn is
your nuclear nuclear sound like george w
bush
and
my guess is when your daughter called
something out in the home here's the way
i feel
your body responded before your head did
i tend to lead with angry there you go
and that's
it's an honest place to come from and i
get that
what would be a great gift
is to tell your daughter
i usually lead with angry and i'm sorry
you need your mama and i'm here
and i know from past counseling that
that's because i have a hard time being
vulnerable
and anger is easier yep well i don't
know if it's easier it just points you
in the direction of something you care
about but being vulnerable is hard if
you're involved will get you killed
yeah you did that once you fell in love
with a guy
and he left
right yeah yeah
so yeah i mean and not to mention you do
trauma for a living so you sit in other
people's
literally in their blood for a living
like you're you're in it 24 7. man your
poor brain is just
it's like uh like that game pong back in
the day
right it's like a ping pong it's like a
tennis match going on up there and so
you've got a lot going on in your body
is your daughter under psychiatric care
right now yes okay
um
i would ask again
um and she might say no and tell her you
don't have to do this
say for your mom's sake i'd love to walk
alongside this with you and if you don't
want me involved in the medical part and
all that kind of stuff i understand
but my promise to you is i'm not gonna
be angry anymore i'm gonna love my baby
girl
it would probably help if you wrote this
down and read it
and maybe even practice it in front of a
mirror in front of a friend
but we are doing a control alt delete on
you and your daughter's relationship
moving forward
okay
okay
are you in
i'm in okay college students have a very
uh college students that age group has a
very distorted perception of time
as though if you take a semester off
everything is over
right i can't even count the number of
semesters off i took i used to
convincing students and their parents
just take a semester off go get a job go
see a counselor get your meds leveled
out and then come back to school it's
like super fine when you're 25 you don't
even know this happened
um i worked at the law students really
close the end it was end of time i
didn't get into law school x and y and
then they end up at law school z and
things are great
their whole life is different right but
right now in that moment it feels super
real and data and info don't help
what helps is i'm so so sorry
and she only applied to one law school
the one at the college that she's at and
she graduated with her bachelor's a year
early she took on so much
in three years that she got her
bachelor's a year early a very common
response to the child of an alcoholic
is looking in the mirror and saying he
chose this over me
i'll give him something to choose me
about
oh that's so sad it is it's
heartbreaking
i will be so perfect
i will make such straight a's and the
crappy part is if a kid chooses drugs
we've got systems for that if a kid
chooses straight a's
as a defense mechanism
they get praised
we just reinforce it over and over and
then they run up against failure which
ev steve jobs got fired right everybody
fails
yeah but when failure when when that
achievement
is the
cheap proxy for love for my dad
and i don't reach
it's devastating
yeah see what i'm saying this wasn't
just not getting into law school this is
dad not loving me all over
and again mentioned she has a younger
half sister who's eight
and she she mentioned that during the
same conversation that she feels like he
treats her differently than than she was
treated at that age and so you say
you're right i'm so sorry
yeah
and make sure she knows
his alcoholism was a pro it was his
issue not yours
and my goodness he missed out on a
wonderful extraordinary woman
oh he did yeah
but that was his problem not hers
yeah and thank god we're not there yet
i've talked to women who get divorced
from men who are idiots and they go on
the men go on to grow up and get a job
and get stable and they marry somebody
else and there's that rage and anger and
then it eventually turns to
thank god somebody's getting experienced
the part of that guy that i loved with a
guy that will actually bathe and go to
work right there will come a moment when
your daughter will look at her
stepsister and say
she's getting full dad which is awesome
i'm glad she's not getting what i got
and she's not going to be there for a
while
right that's okay yeah that's gonna be a
long time yeah absolutely
he gave her the same nickname uh he
always called my daughter a little bit
and he's been calling the younger sister
a little bit instead of my daughter and
it's like she's replaced her
yeah and your husband's probably trying
to breathe and he is trying he he has a
hole the size of your daughter and his
heart that he will never be able to fill
up
good
no no
no no
know i know
i know
but i'm trying to get along with them so
that we can let me tell you this
here's what i want you to do i'm gonna
give you an exercise okay
okay and maybe do it with your daughter
but i want you to do it at home first i
want you to get four or five things that
you're super pissed off about you get
really angry about when you think about
them
okay you probably have a list of 20. i
want you to just get four or five of the
best ones
and i want you to get a piece of masking
tape or duct tape
and i want you to tape them to
actual cinder blocks once you go to home
depot or lowe's or something to get some
cinder blocks
and tape them to them
and then i want you to carry that around
for a while one at a time
just carry on set a timer for 10 minutes
and then when the timer goes off set it
down
and don't pick it back up
and when you set it down your back's
gonna actually ache and your arms will
burn
and so that pain of
that you think that anger is protecting
you is not it's keeping you from taking
a full breath
set it down and when the burning stops
you will feel light and you'll feel good
right
yeah practice this
being less angry is a skill that you
learn it's not a moral issue just stop
practice it okay i want you to lean into
this
so hear me say about your daughter
she has to be under care of a
psychiatric professional i do not like
the trajectory she's on
okay i think she's in a in a dangerous
trajectory i don't like it
she's putting puzzle pieces together
about dead and about this new little
girl and she's going from cutting to
cutting
where it's a borderline attempt to then
i'm taking pills that is a bad
trajectory and when we're looking at
suicidality we're looking at trajectory
our behavior is escalating in hers are
i don't like the way she's isolating
herself
but she did reach out
she did reach out
she doesn't need a bunch of math facts
from her mom she just needs to know
she's not crazy she needs to know that
she's loved and she needs to know she's
anchored into somebody who's working
towards reaching back out
okay
she also probably needs medication she
also needs to be surrounded by
professional care
if she goes back to school somewhere she
needs to be plugged in with all of the
school resources
if at all possible
and at some point hopefully she signs a
release and allows you into those
conversations not for you to go solve it
and to direct traffic for her she's a
grown woman but for you to sit with her
and hold her hand and say hey i think
they need to get there's this resource
available for you or i'll walk alongside
you because this one's going to be hard
there's gonna be some trauma healing
there's gonna be some a path to walk
here
but she needs her mom
okay
so let's set down this crap set it down
let's be about reconnecting
she's lucky to have you own what was and
then be about what comes next stay on
the line i'm gonna send you a copy of my
latest book and i want you to read it
and maybe even pass it along to her if
you find some value in it okay
hang on the line and uh jen will get you
hooked up we'll be right back
hey delony here one of the things i love
about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloni.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
we are back hey um thank you so much for
hanging out with us today on the show
as we wrap up today's show man that's a
great band uh switchfoot fantastic band
it's another phenomenal song here and
song's called meant to live and it goes
like this
fumbling his confidence and wondering
why the world has passed him by hoping
that he's bent for more than arguments
and failed attempts to fly
we were meant to live for so much more
we lost ourselves somewhere we live
inside and we were meant to live for so
much more
somewhere we live inside
we want more than this world's got to
offer
and everything inside screams for second
life
that's what we're doing here kids thank
you for being with us we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode and we are
celebrating today
episode
300. is that right can you believe it
kelly no i can't believe we've been
allowed to stay on air this long it's
unbelievable you haven't gotten us
canceled yet i have not got
what are they called the kids call them
the ama's amas the ask me anythings
question number one worst band ever
smashing pumpkins that's not even a
question i just asked myself anything
and that was the answer i gave